representative government requires a
society
separate from the government big enough
to control
that great power
so we said in the declaration of
independence that the king
was suspending the legislature and
wouldn't let them elect another one
right elect another one the
representatives of the people
are not meeting you see consent gives
rise to representation
now why would that make for a control
on the government
because the government doesn't receive
its legitimacy
without the consent of the governed
yeah and it isn't even abstract
right uh government is
a monopoly you know it's uh if it if
it's true
as we said before that politics is
natural to the human being that they
always live under laws
that it arises from their gift of speech
which is the classical argument and also
the founders argument about
government then there's always going to
be government right and you're going to
be in the government and it's going to
have a monopoly on force
on the other hand it can't really do
anything
unless you say it can and that's not the
king's idea the king's idea is
you're going to have to have kings it's
in the order of nature
i was born to this i'm going to be the
darn
king and you're going to be the people
and i'm supposed to take care of you and
you're supposed to do what i say
and that's not grounded in the consent
of either one of us
we have this station we're stuck with it
once you change that and you say
the government can really only do what
you say it can do
that limits it drastically
and how is the government established
what's the first step in the
establishment of the american government
breaking away from the government we
were under
happened in the uh yeah okay that was
good uh
happened in the uh we have a code
it happened in the what in the
technology yeah we all got that one
right so
[Laughter]
so we get the government right now we've
given consent
is that enough
what else do we need constitutional
instructions yeah
wait because we have to keep giving it
right
you have to give consent to form the
government
but then after that do you need more do
you need to be saying okay
on an ongoing basis because if you do
you're going to need a constitution
what was hitler's constitution like
kindly believe what i say or die yeah he
actually i don't expect your kids to
read my books so i can quote them
[Applause]
hitler came to power in 1933
and hitler wouldn't take the job unless
hindenburg and the
leaders of the maine political parties
would promise
to support an enabling act he called it
that would liberate the government to do
whatever it wanted to do
so hitler's constitution is hitler's
will
and that'll work if one person gets to
make all the decisions
but if a lot of people are going to make
the decision you're going to have to
have some form
by which they can indicate
authoritatively what they agree to
so if you're going to involve a lot of
people in the government
you're going to have to have a
constitution you're going to have to
and you see why the constitution has to
be different
from the things that that is actually in
the law because it prescribes the
process by which the ordinary laws would
be made
it can't be the same as they right
so and that is by the way implied right
through the middle of the declaration of
independence when they talk about the
king messing with the government all the
time in the way that he was doing
you see so consent requires
representation and representation
requires a written way for that to
happen
if you have a constitution you can
spread the decisions out
over time by having representation we've
already said
you spread the decisions out over space
right you can have a bigger country and
everybody can have a say
in it because they don't have to go
there all the time
they can all have the same say in it
but also over time government is by
nature
very powerful it has a monopoly
on power it has to be like that
representative government requires
a society separate from the government
big enough to control that great power
thank you for watching we hope you're
enjoying our highlight series and
invite you to explore all of hillsdale
college's online courses
they are free and for everyone who loves
to learn